françois poule et mathis spécialiste de
l'europe et journaliste françois poulet
mathis bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions échec à moins d'un changement
fondamental de l'union européenne ce
sont les mots de boris johnson tout à
l'heure réelle envie de négocier ou
énième coup de bluff de la part du
premier ministre britannique
je crois que boris johnson s'est fait un
peu piégé en déclarant qu'il fallait
qu'une solution soit trouvée d'ici le 15
octobre faute de quoi il prendrait ses
responsabilités
or l'union européenne n'a jamais exigé
que les négociations s'arrête le 15
octobre l'union européenne et même
accepte même l'idée de deux trois voire
quatre semaines supplémentaires de
négociations
le véritable problème c'est que boris
johnson et vous jamais véritablement
rentrer dans la négociation
il n'était pas prêt il n'était pas prêt
d'ailleurs on l'a vu lorsqu'il a inventé
cette espèce de loi sur le marché
intérieur qui contredit finalement
l'accord de sortie
on le voit aussi dans le fait que la
grande bretagne le royaume uni n'a pas
véritablement préparé ses comptes hier à
l'éventualité d'un odile les douanes ne
sont pas du tout préparés alors que côté
européen on s'est préparés et puis on le
voit aussi dans la mesure où la tension
monte mon jeu johnson espérer que cette
cohésion des douze ne tiennent pas dans
la durée
manifestement on l'a vu à ce conseil
européen les 27 restent soudés et reste
ferme sur leurs objectifs
je rappelle quand même que sur trois
points essentiels les accords n'ont pas
été trouvés ces trois points essentiels
c'est la pêche d'abord les britanniques
veulent récupérer le contrôle larsson
dépêche
ça peut se comprendre mais l'union
européenne et en particulier de pays
comme la france la belgique le danemark
considère qu'il est absolument non
négociable de pouvoir continuer à pêcher
dans les eaux britanniques mais les deux
autres aspect sur lequel les progrès
n'ont pas non plus été accomplis c'est
celui d'un risque de concurrence
exacerbée entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne une fois qu'ils sont
aux sorties c'est à dire la volonté
d'une liberté revendiquée par le royaume
uni
d'être maître de sa législation de m
peut-être remettre de ces
réglementations et de san juan douad et
puis la troisième
le troisième point qui est fondamental
aussi c'est ce qu'on appelle le
règlement des conflits
l'union européenne considère que c'est
très important de pouvoir considérer que
tout conflit doit être arbitrée
notamment par la cour de justice
européenne
or les anglais ne veulent pas en
entendre parler or sur ces trois points
on a vraiment l'impression qu'aucun
progrès n'a été effectuée raison pour
laquelle effectivement brune johnson
parle d'une certaine manière qu'il
faudrait une changement radical de du
comportement du européenne mais seront
le changement n'est pas possible et
n'interviendra pas et donc on est un
petit peu sur une partie de poker je le
répète encore une fois on a vraiment
l'impression que boris johnson est en
train de se faire piéger
emmanuel macron vient de dire nous h au
pont surtout avec londres vous venez de
le dire vous avez évoqué les différents
points d'achoppement justement entre
bruxelles et londres
est-ce que d'ici le 31 décembre on sait
que c'est la fin de cette table de
transition post break ce site est ce
qu'il peut se passer un moment de
consensus ou si on n'y arrive pas qu est
ce qui va se passer ça va être le no
deal c
vraiment ce vers quoi on tend on tend
effectivement vers une tension de plus
en plus forte mais encore une fois je le
répète pour les européens pour les 27
pays de l'union européenne
il n'est pas question d'exiger que le 15
octobre tout soit terminé c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui tout soit terminé
les pays européens sont toujours prêts à
continuer à négocier mais ils savent
très bien que avant de pouvoir trouver
un accord
il faut que cet accord soit viable pour
l'instant on n'est pas encore dans cette
situation où un accord se décident de
manière viable
là est la difficulté donc tout n'est pas
encore fermé et on imagine mal paris
johnson décider demain ou après-demain
de claquer la porte tout simplement bon
il johnson nous a déjà habitué à changer
d'avis on l'a vu lors de l'accord de
sortie puisque il a accepté finalement
une transition sur la question
irlandaise qui n'était pas prévu au
départ et qui a permis cet accord donc
on peut très bien imaginer qu en
dernière limite de boris johnson fils
finissent par lâcher quelques éléments
qui pourraient permettre cet accord de
dernière minute
mais le temps presse le temps presse et
et on peut raisonnablement penser que si
avant le 15 novembre
il n'y a aucun accord possible à ce
moment là ça sera une sortie sans accord
or cela von der leyen la présidente de
la commission européenne a dit tout à
l'heure que les négociateurs de l'union
européenne se rendrait lundi à londres
pour négocier pour intensifier les
négociations qu est ce qu il faut
attendre de ce nouveau round de
négociations de l'impression qu'il
sanchez que c'est un énième un énième
dans un énième round de négociations
avec encore aujourd'hui sur le ce
conseil européen
c'est toujours ce qui suit des
négociations souterraines ou finalement
ces négociations souterraines n'ont pas
avancé et donc il faut que les
responsables se rejoignent et essaye de
trouver la faille
c'est à dire l'élément sur lequel on
peut accepter pour les européens par
exemple des certaines concessions
je pense à des concessions par exemple
sur les zones de pêche sur lequel
effectivement les européens pourraient
faire à un petit effort envers mme
envers les britanniques mais les
britanniques de leur côté ils doivent
accepter le fait qu'on ne peut pas
quitter
l'union européenne tout en gardant tous
les avantages que lui à la grande
bretagne dispose en 10e pour disposer le
royaume uni en restant dans l'union
européenne
on ne peut pas avoir le beurre et
l'argent du beurre c'est peut-être ce
que n'a pas véritablement encore compris
boris johnson merci françois pour les
mathis d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe et auteur
notamment de l' ouvrage brésil
une chance qu'on interrogations aux
éditions hauteur du monde